[Music]
please
join me in welcoming iwei shea
all right thank you um good morning
everyone um
so i'm ejoy um firstly i would like to
thank rob for
sharing all these touching love stories
with armadan
and well actually before i get started i
have a few horror stories to share first
one is that i don't have slides today
oh terrible second is i only have an r
script
which i opened here and what i got
what we are going to do for this talk is
that i will explain the
r script line by line for 20 minutes i'm
just kidding
third thing is that i'm going to do live
demos
and i would like to introduce you hoy's
law of doing
live demos which is live demos
always work before you step onto the
podium
all right let's see if i will succeed
anyway okay
so i'm going to source this script
well actually i still have a few more
horror stories
first one is i'm going to use the iris
data for demonstration
oh that's terrible i
if that's that's not horrible enough
okay i have another horror story i'm
going to use pie charts
oh even better right uh
still not if that steel does not scare
you
i'm going to use three-dimensional pie
charts and animated pie charts
okay all right thank you for staying in
the room
still staying with me here all right
let's
get started for real so because i don't
have enough time i'm going to type out
type out my example here just
really fast all right of course i'm
cheating
yeah i wrote a blog blog post on how i
cheated so you can go back and check out
that blog post
all right so i've got a markdown
document
which is precisely 100 lines i think
people with
ocd will feel very comfortable with that
100 lines
no more no less okay i think this is a
pretty simple example
we just have some sections some article
chunks that produces
produce plots and tables and equations
and also some dynamic and interactive
content so the first demo i'm going to
show you is the
probably the most boring one the html
document output
so i'm going to compile this
automatically
and here we here's the output there's
nothing new
basically a very an ordinary html out
uh the document so yeah i
just did some text output here i
drew a scatter plot over actually a
two-dimensional density plot overlaid by
a
so-called sunflower plot and i call this
my version of starry night
i don't know if it actually looks like a
starry night
anyway so i've got a table here i've got
a linear regression model here so all
these things are dynamically generated
and here's our horrible pie chart
which is a pyramid chart
the sky the blue sky the sunny side of
the pyramid
and shady side of pyramid oh
yeah don't apply i don't applaud yet
because i have a better one
the animated pie chart which is a
pac-man
so just just to show you that you can do
animations
um from our markdown and i've also got
dynamic interactive content which are
html widgets
so this shows where we are right now so
here's the hilton
the hotel and i've also got the boring
iris data
in the data tables it's interactive you
can
go to different pages you can sort the
columns you can search
in the in the table so that
shows some of the most common components
of
the armature document next what i'm
going to do
is to insert a css code chunk
so here i've got a css code chunk which
is really simple what i did here is that
i set the background color
of the document to be black and i
applied a css filter to this document to
invert all the colors
so hopefully you'll see what it looks
like in a minute
so here with just two lines of css code
i
turned this document into the dark mode
so now i've got dark mode
i think the dark mode aligns very well
with my horror story theme
and now this starry night i
i don't know maybe it has turned to it
has become like
something like a virus night or
zombie night i don't know well you can
see yeah
the text is text is white and dark and
the background is black and yeah the
pyramid also looks scary the
sky is red it's it is red and
also pac-man oh it looks like a ghost
now
and also our leaflet interactive leaflet
map
the whole hilton hotel looks like a
haunted hotel now
look just look at those all those forks
and
knives icons i guess the protein you are
not sure if
these are the places where you eat or
get eaten
wow okay i think it looks horrible
enough
the next example i'm going to show you
is that actually
you can make your html output
respond to your uh the the the
your system's theme so what i'm going to
do is that i will just
add a media query to this css
to these css rules so basically that
means
when my uh
the the theme of my
system is dark this document
will automatically go to the dark mode
see if i switch to dark mode then
my document switches dark mode switch
light mode and becomes the light mode
so it can respond to your the appearance
of your operating system
so just with like two lines of css code
i think that's
pretty amazing
[Music]
next i'm going to show you a pdf and
latex document output what i'm going to
do is that i will add
two latex packages to this document one
is animate the other is coffee four
you will know what this pack that what
these package
packages do in a moment so i'm going to
compile this
latex document to pdf and show you the
output
there's actually another danger of doing
live demos which is
i often have to stand here in awkward
silence
waiting for our markdown to finish
the compilation so the end oh well the
coffee for package actually adds
some coffee stains your document
i still don't know why you should do
that probably sometimes you can show to
your advisor or your boss oh look i'm
i'm working really hard i'm still
reading the paper while drinking coffee
all right
yeah the coffee stains can be random
like
just like that yeah
all right next let me show you the
animation stuff uh the animation
actually only works in
the acrobatic reader so i need another
reader to open this pdf
file all right here we go
and now we we've got the pacman here
it actually works in pdf and i click
click on it
yeah it'll start biting
that's the animation and coffee stains
in
pdf output so our next
example is going to be
word document yeah this is your favorite
output format right
but it's my least favorite it's my least
favorite
output format anyway i will show you uh
so basically what i did here is i used a
custom word template
which is specified in the reference docx
option
so that that is a template i made in
advance let's compile this
and see what it looks like oh why is it
your favorite
favorite output format looks horrible
sorry i'm cheating i'm
i opened the word document in text edit
on mac os
let me switch to windows because i don't
have office installed on
my mac os
all right all right so here we
we are on windows now um yeah so this is
the
what the output looks like so i made a
template simply by
like inserting an image in the header so
i applied that template to the
markdown document so now you've got the
word output that looks like this
all right so the next one is
next demo is also your favorite another
of your
favorite output format which is
powerpoint presentation
i did a similar thing i applied a custom
template to the armageddon document
and we will see the output
yeah of course i still need to switch to
windows
because i don't have powerpoint
installed
how did i get the magnifier look
i don't use windows very often i'm very
slow and windows is also very slow
[Music]
powerpoint
yeah i just basically i just randomly
chose a template
in powerpoint and applied that to to the
armageddon document so
yeah it looks like it works
sometimes it looks messy but yeah the
the content is still there and the
pac-man
is still working hard
all right that's powerpoint oh i find
that i can turn off windows
shutdown oh yeah because the rest for
the rest of the demos and i won't need
windows
uh where am i now
all right so the next demo is uh
io slice presentation so you can create
multiple types of
slides like html slides pdf slides or
powerpoint
so here i'm going to show you a type of
html slides named i o slides
so i'm only using the default options
you can see still the same content there
but with html i personally i'm i really
love html slides because it's so much
more flexible
for example with like a single key press
you can go to the overview mode and and
again with the single co
keystroke you can turn this to the wide
screen mode or just
the normal mode so take that challenge
powerpoint
all right so that is html slides
[Music]
next demo is beamer presentation and
that's kind of dangerous because i
almost
i i almost always feel sleepy when i
look at beamer slides
so me sorry rob
yours looks fantastic
all right so beamer you can actually
chose some themes from the arts video
ide
so for example here we we have the you
can change
output options and choose different
themes there for example you can switch
to
berkeley and see what that looks like
so this is the original theme i used
anyway if we change to another theme and
knit this document again
you can see a different theme
oh it's blue that's my least favorite
favorite color in bimmer
alright beamer
and the next demo is the tafty package
so tafty package provides
the style created by edward tafty and
it it actually you can actually create
html out performance and
pdf output so here i'm showing you the
html format so still
same content all the plots the tables
are
all there the one of the main
characteristics
of the tafty theme is of the tattoo
style is
that the it has a main column on the
right on the left hand side
and it also has a sidebar on the right
hand side
so there are certain things that can be
placed in a sidebar for example like
figure caption or table caption
or footnotes or your citations you can
also have some
full-width elements like the map
and this is actually a very responsive
layout for example if your screen is
very narrow for example
when you are reading this page on your
mobile phone
well actually i don't know why you
should read anything on your mobile
phone like read a paper
well but yeah it's just a possible
the the the layout can uh respond to the
page with so that is the tafty theme
and next one is the rolldown package
this is a new package
i wrote last year and my mo my
my main motivation for this for
developing this package is uh
actually lama because i saw a javascript
library
named screw lama and i saw that that
sounds cute
let me write an r package for it so
i wrote an r package named rodan in
which
creates an html page that looks like
this
so roll down basically means when you
scroll down
a document you can display
different things in the main area so for
example
originally i was displaying this scatter
plot and then as i scroll down
look at you can take a look at on the
left hand side where i put some
all the text and sections and things
like that there
so as you scroll down you can highlight
certain things like your
plots your tables and things like that
and i think this is also a very a very
interesting output format
so just scroll down and certain things
will change
is the rolldown package and we've also
got
uh the demo for uh
journal articles so that is one of the
output formats from the articles package
articles without a just so i'm using the
gss underscore article format
so again the same document and
different output oops
yeah so i guess some of you might have
submitted
papers to gss and i just want to show
you that it's also possible to write
a jss paper with our markdown
are actually i'm uh we i'm not sure how
wide
uh our articles uh the articles packages
will be used because of the you know the
stock
the stockholm syndrome when latex
tortures you enough you will fall in
love with fall in love with it
so yeah i'm not sure how markdown how
wide
markdown will be used for writing
journal papers but we will see
so that is the articles package anyway
you can also create a dashboard
from this the same document so
now i'm using the flex dashboard package
and now you can see my first level
section headings have become
pages second level section
headers have become columns we have four
uh
second level section headings here so we
have four columns
in in this dashboard and yeah
again the pacman is still working there
and we fly yeah
interactive map also works here
and also it's actually responsive in the
sense that
it responds to your page width so if the
page
is too narrow you can see the layout
will automatically
change so that is the dashboard
next next demo is um
page down so we have an output format
named
we actually have several output formats
in the page down package
one of them is book book underscore crc
that is a style for the publisher
chapman
chapman hall so let's compile this
document to
that output format so page down is a
package for
creating pdfs from html
and we style the html pages with css
it is there's also a backend
there's also a javascript backend which
like makes all these pages on the html
page
so you can see it looks quite so
sophisticated right
if you want a pdf you just press ctrl p
or command p
you can print this to a beautiful pdf
and i swear this is html this is not pdf
here
i can open the javascript console for
you i can type a few a few lines of
javascript
to show you oh this is really html and
then you can see all the css associated
with
these elements there so it's in my web
browser it's not pdf but you can create
a
pdf
from this html page
so the next demo is
book done so book now also contains
several output formats what i'm
demonstrating here is
an output format named beatbook so the
same document
is compiled to a book with multiple
chapters
you can navigate through these chapters
and you can toggle the table of contents
which is in
uh a sidebar you can change the
typeface you can change the font size
you can change the theme
it's very flexible so that is
book done and next
i'm going to demonstrate the learner
package
learner allows you to create interactive
tutorials
from markdown so this is an interactive
tutorial created from that same
markdown document so it has several
topics you can navigate through these
topics and sometimes
you can also specify the code chunks to
be exercises
so that your students can like run the
code
right there and they can change
the code and rerun so they can play with
the code freely
here
just let let me go back to my horror
theme again change the
uh color of the sky to be black yeah it
still works right
so all right that's the learner package
so my last demo is
block down so i will copy
that our markdown document to a block
down website
and compile that website hopefully you
will see that website
in a minute
all right so this is the website i'm
using the hugo academic theme
so we can scroll down to find our demo
file
there one our markdown document for 14
demos
still everything is still there
pac-man has turned his head to the right
all right so that is the block down
package
um
[Music]
all right so i i think that's pretty
much what i have got for you today and
people often say oh markdown marketing
is just so simple
i mean i i cannot create sophisticated
sophisticated applications with markdown
i just want to show
show them that they are wrong there are
a lot of things that you can
that you can do with markdown and our
markdown
thank you
[Applause]
i know we have lunch right now so we
don't have too much time for questions
but
the one with the most votes right now is
what's the up dog app
what what's that what what's up dog or
up dog oh i'm sorry i i should have
deleted that section in a block down
book
yeah book yeah app dog is right it's
done
okay second question then if we can do
this one
what is the difference between book down
and page down
book down and page down uh book done
well
the main the focus of page down is html
but for book done it supports html pdf
and even word documents yeah
yeah page lines may need to use css to
type set your
html documents
thank you all right thank you
you